températ
[Musique]
3105 c'est beau la rivière qu'on voit en
face c'est joli ça pas monter plus Cuse
la
vis je pense que plus
[Musique]
voir demain il faut qu'on quit à 12h30
dernier ok allez une
merde mer ah
ou coupe
att coup on peut poser vite fait
vousz le
contact merci de votre accueil à très
bientôt
monsieur à la
prochaine pas faire de BR y en avait une
mais
trouverutre tout
faire un gros troupeau à droite là je
pas
bon
[Musique]
tu vois ce que dire ce village avec des
grand rond noir
autour
photographinormément je P en allant sur
sur voil
c'estés
libert
là surt à droite ah d'accord ok moi j'
sur le FL
tu peux doucement aller vers la droite
des belles
couleurs graphism
devant pe l'ombre
al à
[Musique]
droite faut qu'on avance quandme
vas-y avance
avance on va traverser peut-être on va
traverser le flu peut-être le coup de le
faire de reste film je sais qu'on a
traversé le flu peut-être qu'est-ce que
tu en penses
découlage à unité
504 rappelez pour les
estimé la
destination
à 29 15h29 et la destination
à0 et bien r vous passtez quelle
altitude on approche 3000
en appelez sa
la matière au sol travailler un
peu c'est beau
ça
émission de télé par là Mo j du
ciel
mamion sur Delta del les G qui vivent
dedans anim unu de mal par
contre de
pauvretéposer là le
monol le rocher ah
pass une semaine avec eux tu vis
avec eux tu vas pêcher tu fais
toutesmion tu es gentil je fais un
plateau par
jour maisi il tout le temps devant lui
artistes c'est très beau devant devant
c'est magnifique j'arve dev c'est
magnifique rivière un petit
truc non faut pas que tu non finir ou
tuurais pas d quitter l'horizon ça va
arriver
OK
s là tu
vois aprs un Dakar après le Dakar non
après la TransAfricaine pas après le
Dakar
on pour faire moi je suis prêt à le
faire ça si on peut le monter ensemble
aucun
problème aucun problème
on se B iici tu vois et on tourne un peu
autour
[Musique]
onre pas mal je
pense
vir avec le point pas trop
[Musique]
cher
superet par ex on tra comm le film res
dans
laelli
tu pens à droite ouais ouais ok merci le
Fame rocher d'IER
ài un oiseau ouais ài il vient de passer
il a un petit vage juste en bas
J on est passé ici hier non l'impression
que je te dis regarde le rocher devant
ESS de nous unu ver
les DEL à droite vachement nmen unu par
là
on pas fait de grand troup
ai par contre a d monter plusut je pense
que ment aller je pense
pas un peu chaud qu c'est
bonud
des
petits arbres
là magnifique
paysage
un pe ouais allez
ouis tu pouras le faire tout à l'heure
mais là on plus de soleil
alle
un peu
[Musique]
drite
je prense à
droite
oui
voilà
ouis c'est vachement beau
ça
ver c'est beau
je te
dis
pas CELI ce n'est pas celui-là Ahou
d'accord incroyable
ce
elle passe un peu plus prê ça devrait
être
bon hier on l'a fait de toute
façon c'est peut-être un peu plus je
sais pas 'est tuux pass pr ou pas non
bien par que hier on éit les dedans
dedans ded ded
[Musique]
crocodile vu comme qui
remontetit village dans l'eau là
encore de vant des villages de dans
l'eau d'ailleurs
[Musique]
beaucoup dans
complet
[Musique]
pass
un peu à droite
[Musique]
ou mais
un problème avec le
[Musique]
rô
est-ce que tu vois bien le côté gauche
de ton
image
[Musique]
de je pense que c'est sur
phot
a coup